dearest viewer
the following is a recollection and to
the best of my abilities an honest
assessment of the details
and my own subsequent feelings toward
the eighth and most recent in one wes
anderson's illustrious filmography
if you can glean even an ounce of the
joy and vibrance i experienced in my
brief patronage of this exhibition
my camp shall be happy and i it's
equally happy occupant
will have been thoroughly sated au
revoir
what up home slices ham sandwiches
pork products it's your boy it's your
man
it's jerry and i am here today to talk
to you about a film i got to see last
week
uh wes anderson's new movie the grand
budapest hotel
i was actually lucky enough to see this
twice last week
it's in limited release right now and uh
if you get a chance
definitely check it out it's this movie
is a lot of fun
um it's kind of different from a lot of
wes anderson's previous movies to me
anyway
in the sense that it's very fast paced
like lots of stuff
happens um not that it doesn't but like
this movie
really has a really snappy kinetic
rhythm
um but still all those you know wes
anderson frills
uh we've come to know and love a lot of
his regulars are back in this one
you know you got jason schwartzman you
got willem dafoe
jeff goldblum owen wilson bill murray
those guys pop up
tilda swinton and then you got f murray
abraham and harvey keitel
and edward norton seriously ronan is in
this
a young man named uh tony revolori i
think his name is plays
zero who's the lobby boy who's sort of
telling this story
and i don't think you can talk about
this movie without mentioning ray fines
um ray finds is just so
great in this movie i hate using like
cliche
movie terms like this but but it is a
pitch perfect performance as uh
gustav h the hotel concierge who
takes zero under his wing his rhythm and
his cadence and his
just the whole way he plays this
character is so perfect and so
believable and so
fun to watch and i really hope he gets
recognized for it
uh because he's just magical in this
movie
the film itself is
like i said it's very twisty and turning
there's a lot of stuff that happens it's
a period piece so it's kind of like one
of those
sort of crazy uh larger than life you
know autobiographical stories
that you would hear about in the old
days full of intrigue and and mystery
and
strange and colorful characters and
stuff like that the movie has a very
eastern european flair
they shot it all i believe in germany uh
and
what's also cool is they use a lot of
different techniques as wes anderson is
known to
the film is shot on a few different
stocks
so there's a shift in aspect ratio a
couple times which is cool
and they use a lot of miniatures in
really cool ways
um which added an air of magic to
everything
and you know like any west interested
movie the photography is beautiful very
symmetrical
there are lots of very interesting
colors that are that are bold and stand
out
the dialogue is is a lot of fun and this
is a movie
i got to see this twice and i'm really
happy about that because
this one especially has so much going on
and so many little details and so many
little lines that are easy
to miss in you know the rhythm of the
film
and this is one of those films that i
i'm sure the more times you watch it the
more you'll get out of it
so definitely see it a couple times if
you can plus it you know it's dazzling
on the big screen
i'm using all these cliche words but um
yeah if you get a chance
definitely check it out i think it's
going into wide release next week or in
a couple weeks
if you're a wes anderson fan i think
you'll definitely enjoy it and i've
heard some folks say that they're not
wes anderson fans and they have still
enjoyed this movie
i know some people complain that
moonrise kingdom was like wes anderson
times 20 you know like just really
really wes anderson style this movie
definitely has that but it
seems a little it seems a little less
concerned with that style and more about
just the story and and the style really
fits the story
oh also the score is really cool too
alexander despla does the score
and um you know it's it's very sort of
fast and kinetic and
and you know very eastern european
influence
so um yeah highly recommended uh if
you've seen it let me know what you
think
and what's your favorite wes anderson
movie let's let's talk about wes
and um yeah comment and subscribe and
stuff
and you can hit us up on the tweets i am
reasons to jerry or there's also the
real rejects account
uh so yeah